[Music]
No
get up Britney ow good morning John it's
Tuesday May 1st that was New York Times
bestselling author Hugo Award winner
Nebula Award winner and all-around
awesome nerdfighter guy Neil Gaiman now
I know that you're a writer and that you
hang out with writers and that you
always have good writers on Brotherhood
2.0 but now I've got one I may have had
to wait in a very very long line to get
one but I got one and he's saying hi
congratulation mr. Koh LA Times Book
Award that's a big deal congratulations
to you Jon for getting nominated and
since I know a lot of the nerdfighters
there Neil Gaiman fans and I know a lot
of the nerdfighter is one of someday be
writers I'm gonna share with you a clip
from Neil's lecture that I
surreptitiously captured someone asked
him if there was really anything better
than seeing your name on the spine of a
book and having watched you go through
this Jon I can attest that he is right
I'm actually pretty sure that you fell
victim to gaymans law which says that as
soon as your first book is published you
will go to the bookstore and over the
book to a random page on which you will
find possibly the only typographical
error in your entire book and then you
will want to kill yourself
so here's Neil talking about being an
author all those things that when you're
a kid you think I just did that once
who would ever need any but you're 14
you finally
so there you have it thanks for
challenging you to write more songs as a
commenter pointed out it is actually
kind of difficult and requires lots of
creative energy so I can't guarantee
anything um sometimes you just draw a
blank right so there were other reasons
besides Neil Gaiman that I was in Helena
Montana that was weird
whoa oh okay I think I think it's I'm
first on Montana
Montana gold cows and chopping trees
these are the industries of how and on
Montana butter and there were peeps in
the gutter Oh Hannah Montana Montana we
frisbee at the Capitol and looked and
lots of belt buckles how in our
Montana's check your guns at the door
fat guy in a candy store Helena Montana
[Music]
well I don't know if that was anything
like as catchy as the Helen Hunt song
but maybe it'll bump it out of some of
you guys as heads still no progress on
that me not being paid for my work front
and I'm very excited that Co booth
thinks I'm hot and I'd like to say hi to
Francesca Lia block and to all of the
other amazing people who said hi to me
in the last video blog hello to you all
we may not be famous but we got famous
people on the Brotherhood well I'll see
you tomorrow